hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to welcome to the game
now I didn't do so good last time
because I didn't know exactly what I was
supposed to do but I have to start a new
game because I died and then I was the
victim in the red room and I'm dead so I
need to start over and this time I'm
gonna make a very meticulous list of the
websites that I've been due so that I
know shut up Adam I know what I'm doing
so that I know exactly where to go and
I'm gonna have my notepad up ready to go
and these are a little bit different
than they were before so I gotta go
through this all carefully like it's a
little early but let's go check out the
bathroom cams because dozer dammit
dammit I just got started
all right fine you bring on your hats
actor I'm doing boss blocker huh the
easy crap
speed it up Oh champion okay so now
they're gonna go through this I don't
think I'm gonna be ported this early on
I don't think I'm gonna be doing
anything that I've got going on so I
just need to go through and I need to
find websites that I can actually go to
pour through them get every single
little detail I can what's this one
again see why that why that one over
there why that one there's nothing here
it's the same thing I believe this might
be a red herring so I'm pretty sure
that's a red herring but that was the
same one in the other one too chosen
away again get some extra laughs in
there all right we got typing up a storm
I think I know what I'm doing hashtag
fine piece app slinger underscore
underscore H hashtag boop peg define IP
underscore half-life 2 IP 0 0 X 0 F BAM
got it ding-dong ping pong okay I'm not
dead yet family drug shop get old
friendly fam Oh heroin all of your
family needs products we need to go
through the whole website if there's
nothing here then there's nothing here
but I need to find out
Lee how much is here why ours a lot of
hacks Oh what what what why you mean
fail what did i do I didn't get a chance
to do anything huh he's lost for for
what do you mean four days lost would
they put me in a time prison the [ __ ]
was that all about
okay so I guess I'm okay so I gotta find
out what kind of hair oh and I can get
at this point I'd welcome an abductor
cuz I'm not ready
ah there we go
okay now I got it cuz apparently you
only get one chance on that that's super
we OH toad toad toad Bank Oh got it
okay even though I lost today that
doesn't matter I got it done
family drug shop done father Donald had
something but father Donald was only
available like 3:00 a.m. last time so
it's okay hot burners is done I can
remember now how burners has nothing
okay that's fine that's good okay we're
good
Illuminati the website nope doesn't work
I'm gonna test out cuz I think there's
random noises that aren't actually
anything I don't know that though tango
Down yes okay got something three CFE
okay got it all right that's good that's
good
all right we got something we got
another one oh that's good okay tango
down we got it how many huh oh no no oh
no oh my goodness gracious
like what would be hacked
what Oh
load of ass ah man I must not fully
understand that I think I had to go let
it go through the other loop first and
then circle back to it but man that's
that's awfully inconvenient Oh again
because it's day six I'm gonna have to
million ways oh man this is not going
well is going much worse than the last
one
okay goddamn you got that done and I'll
make that look like Oh stepping fast
instead of slow and stupid bunker has
nothing I checked everything the bunker
doesn't have anything I see you
okay oh I see it there it is okay I got
three healthy Hey whoo that is weird
what's the loup-garou we are the sons
and daughters of the loup-garou our
beloved mother long ago our great mother
made a pact with the merciful Lucifer
this pact with mean order for her to
continue to serve us okay I don't like
the whispering I mean I don't like
whispering in general because I'm a loud
mother humper do it as a bring blood no
not at grabbing bring blonder loup-garou
ain't got nothing we're good we're good
Luger ooh
we're fine okay we post nothing all
right got it got it got it
good good good okay I checked every
button checked everything we're good
there so I need to go back from the
bottom to the top the top to bottom
again skipping over the things that I
know got nothing won't give me the
bathroom dams okay so I definitely think
the small noises or anything they're
definitely not that someone that gets me
all the time okay so I think what
happens happened it has to hit every
node that you can change and then the
end gets unlocked that's nice okay so
that makes sense and him who was seated
on it from his presence earth and sky
fled away okay there got four got four
we're doing great
I wrote down where I got him okay so
it's late night now there's a lot of
things in the beginning that don't seem
to work so I'm just checking through the
ones that I have for any late night ones
that may work chosen awake didn't seem
to do anything weird like it doesn't
seem to do anything well I'm guessing
I'm gonna have some abductors crawling
um about very soon David these don't
work hi at that point I could have
punched you and I could have get
delivered a wicked uppercut I did not
know you were there god dammit god
dammit ah ah ah am I supposed to check
regularly I don't know goddamn it Oh
[ __ ] god damn it I'm gonna go again
I'm gonna go again I don't wanna I don't
want to I don't want to be back at the
same point where I was before I want to
get four again and then I can in this
episode and I can finish it up in
another episode because there is a way
to continue but I just wasn't able to
get to it cuz I'm an idiot like here's
God a mess okay this time when I'm gonna
do is number one I'm not gonna get
hacked that guy was probably waiting
there for days just like he's got it
turn around eventually my policy book
says I must do this
I believe the noises are something now I
definitely think that the noises are
most certainly something okay so cotton
road definitely nothing I checked every
single button there's nothing on cotton
road okay forgive me ooh whoa sometimes
I wish my family and friends were dead
just to see if I'd be sad screw me well
now maybe a serial killer I don't know
when but I know why I hate a lot of
people mostly [ __ ] and [ __ ] maybe
I'm thinking I'll do it because I'm 18
and I'll still get through
testosterone-fueled anger I was thinking
that maybe if I click through this
enough there would be something here
that looks like a code but it's all just
really messed up confessions from a lot
of really unsettled people but it seems
like nothing here so I'm gonna put
nothing for forgive me there's code okay
then I saw a great white throne
and him I'm also gonna write down where
I got it from his present
that's the fire-god I could think of
those some stiff stepping tiptoe and
behind me
uh I don't know there's a lot of numbers
in there how am I supposed to if there's
like a minus symbol in there maybe I
don't wanna I don't want to overlook
this say it's this seems like it's gonna
be a red herring but I don't want to
overlook it and be like oh no I want to
be sure if there's a single minus symbol
okay I may have overlooked it but I do
not see anything in that big wall of
text that looks like a minus symbol so
I'm gonna assume that it's nothing okay
I'm gonna assume it's nothing so was
that one Legion quite nothing question
mark that's what I'm gonna put for
Legion oh Jesus yeah fine totally fine
just hack nothing writing the back I get
through this it's Colonel hack I can tip
type flashbacks to my days with Mavis
Beacon sniff those strings baby sniff em
get sniff action string string a Const
and the string ooh nook way right BAM
okay easy peasy lemon squeeze me oh my
god oh my god oh wow you're kidding me
right
where is it what wait
you did the ding where is it okay this
is so absurd because these buttons down
here also count but it dinged where's my
code I'm not a fool I'm literally not
seeing it oh you can't do that to me oh
no you can't do it oh man if you guys
see it then I'm I'm very sorry I don't
think it's here I'm looking I'm looking
so closely
[Music]
okay so I marked the bunker down for a
yes question mark because eight did
something I just don't know why tips
whoa was that whoa what is that oh oh oh
oh my god oh my god who's on my desktop
what is that oh oh that's probably like
the hardest one to get because they
wouldn't the oh boy
don't don't screw this one up vamo
blammo blammo blam oh I got you
shut up [ __ ] you okay we got it oh so we
got the headlock but I did not know it
was just filling this up so I can't get
today 30 or else it'll be game over
who'd know that hey I didn't know that
what about a book that's got about
something because I clicked on it I did
click I clicked it it just didn't do
what I needed to do
God there we go
yes okay there we go that's too
stressful
what come on I need to click on that
thing it's gotta be some oh boy okay
there's gonna be oh no oh no oh jeez oh
boy that was a close one I did not look
at it very closely when it first went
through okay well I got that one too
why would another oh so many buttons on
this page why are there so many bugs so
many buttons at least some go through
the hard ones first maybe then it'll be
easier for me okay that's going that way
this needs to go down down
okay yeah we got it okay that we're good
we're good we're good what do you mean
time I don't know how to me oh I can't
make it go faster that's right okay
there's nothing anyway nothing
[Music]
get on my desktop
ooh there we go okay got it
okay all right okay so that's three
that's all I need for now and supposedly
there's a way to continue the game after
this so I'm doing good I meticulously
went through everything and I think I
got the hard ones out of the way so if I
got the hard ones out of the way that's
good that means the rest of them are
just that ones that appear on the page
by themselves which hopefully I can get
so we'll see about this so thank you
everybody so much for watching if I
somehow screw up and I'm not able to
continue my game we'll see about that
but I think actually I think I have to
get to the next day for it to save and
then go so I'm gonna do that but I'm
gonna do that afterwards you guys don't
have to worry about that unless I die
for some reason so thank you everybody
so much for watching as always I will
see you in the next video bye-bye
holy [ __ ] everything about that
stairwell screams I'm gonna die